le 7-8 sport nouvelle édition huitième
édition depuis le début de l'année merci
de nous rejoindre sur tv fil pour ce
rendez-vous 26 minutes pour faire le
tour de l'actualité sportive bonsoir
anthony ont soir wilfried bonsoir à tous
ce soir évidemment nous parlerons de la
saison 2013 delà de la base de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines avec
vincent couteau et guillaume durand
bonsoir à tous les deux on se rend
compte vous retrouvera tout à l'heure
mais tout d'abord on va s'intéresser au
tennis de table et la belle aventure qui
continue un pur pour l'entendre deux
voisins saint-arnoult les féminines avec
geoffrey nisand leur entraîneur bonsoir
à vous alors on s'était vus il ya
quelques semaines ici même d'ailleurs
sur le plateau vous veniez de de monter
en n2
la belle aventure était déjà bien
entamée et là à mi-saison d'ailleurs je
vous propose de regarder de le
classement tout de suite puisque vous
êtes deuxièmes derrière derrière
joué-lès-tours le favori de cette poule
avec avec deux victoires et une défaite
donc un bilan plutôt satisfaisant on le
voit d'ailleurs sept points voilà
saint-arnoult voisins je voulais tour 9
points et l'encours l'autre club saint
quentinois de cette poule qui s'en sort
pas si mal ce qu'ils s'en sortent
d'ailleurs très très bien vous êtes
plutôt satisfait en tant qu'entraîneur
justement de ce bilan
oui mais on pensait pas avoir à être
deuxième à la mi-saison les mal parti on
est une défaite assez sévère sur
poitiers une équipe ont pensé pouvoir
raccrocher en fin de compte après les
filles se sont mis à niveau et donc on a
deux bonnes victoires un indice de 1 10
3 ça plutôt pas mal pour ça met en
confiance pour la suite de la saison
exactement on sait que le match est plié
au bout de cinq six matches donc déjà
elles peuvent jouer relâché le sol et
sur ces matches-là
maintenant on va toujours chercher le
maintien il faut encore un match pour
être sûr de se maintenir
j'espère aller chercher ce week-end à
nîmes il reste combien de matchs pour la
saison 4 4 matchs et une seule victoire
nécessaire pour le maintien vous êtes
sûr mais il est très il est très modeste
humble peut-être aussi ses humbles et
alan plus les deux victoires que vous
avez vues sur ces premières journées
c'est face à deux poids lourds de
nationale 2 2 clubs habitués de ce
championnat
en l'occurrence nice et fontenay et ça
aussi c'est une preuve voilà que que le
niveau de vos filles et est satisfaisant
oui parce que ces deux équipes qui ont
terminé troisième en nationale 2 en
première phase en plus nice à renforcer
sur nous donc ça permet ccd bonne
victoire
il nous reste les deux équipes les plus
faibles à jouer donc je pense qu'on peut
quand même aller chercher le maintien
bouteilles et les filles bérengère
salomé aurore camille vous surprennent
en termes de niveau de jeu
oui il a fallu qu'elles manquent leur
niveau de jeu c'est un tout autre niveau
avant elle avait une fille qui était de
leur niveau à jouer sur les quatre
maintenance et quatre filles de leur
niveau voire plus fort donc il faut bien
aller chercher le match on peut dire
cette première défaite au final à
poitiers c'était un petit peu un coup de
stress une certaine appréhension de la
vie partisane parce qu'ils ont versé
voilà ça le tank et s'acclimate à
peut-être à ce niveau c'est
l'apprentissage du niveau tout
simplement c'est la première fois
qu'elle partait pas favorite sur un
match depuis deux ans bon bah on peut
pas tout gagner mais c'est un bon
apprentissage je pense qu'elles sont
remis en question pour les matches
suivants et ne s'était pas forcément dit
que si on avait gagné poitiers on aurait
gagné les deux suivants mais le risque
aujourd'hui c'est pas de faire justement
un excès de confiance justement là on
maintient à maintien après si on peut
jouer autre chose on jouera à autre
chose mais l'idée principale c'est de se
maintient on sait que vous leur dites de
garder la traite fois la tête froide
il faut avoir le match vous leur dites
toujours et il faut deux passes on peut
perdre n'importe quelle équipe votre
discours ressemble beaucoup à celui de
guy roux quand même un le maintien le
maintien mais vous êtes deuxièmes du
championnat
aujourd'hui auxerre n'est pas deuxième
malheureusement et en plus de ses
victoires
ça vous permet d'avoir un peu ce statut
de favori maintenant puisque vous seriez
même l'équipe à battre dans cette poule
avec deux victoires oui pour l'instant
on est l'équipe à battre mais on verra
si on le restera encore et si tout se
passe bien
j'ai regardé un petit peu le évidemment
le calendrier de ce championnat
il pourrait y avoir une dernière journée
assez haletante presque une finale en
fin de compte pour la montée si on fait
aucune erreur jusqu'au dernier match
effectivement ce sera le vainqueur du
dernier match qui montera donc joué les
tours je veux les tours où nous si on
gagne mais et vous y croyez quand même
pour la santé des transports ce match
voilà pour l'instant on est sur les
autres matches l'as des matchs bien
important pour le maintien avant on
verra une semaine avant si il ya quelque
chose à jouer ou pas sur ce match
mais qu'est ce qui fait la réussite de
votre équipe puisque on le rappelle
voilà c'est une équipe assez jeune entre
camille qu'a mis à part salomé qui à 27
ans le reste des défis sont très jeunes
en dessous de 20 ans on aurait pu croire
justement voilà une panique totale
à l'arrivée et finalement banon se
débrouille très bien chaque samedi
elles ont l'avantagé donc d'avoir salomé
qui a déjà un peu d'expérience donc le
qu'elle s'entende bien ça permet d'avoir
déjà une fille qui gagne un peu plus de
match puis une fille qui peut leur
expliquer comment gérer elle est un peu
maman on va se coucher tôt mais derrière
non elle raison envie de progresser
elles s'entendent bien s'il y en a une
qui est pas bien un jour on sait que les
autres rattrape un peu le coup donc ça
permet d'avoir une équipe assez homogène
et donc de de pallier à un mauvais match
de lune ou une maladie
mais à un moment il va falloir rencontré
il encourt aussi c'est pour c'est pour
bientôt parce que le derby se profile
aussi c'est le sera il en coin
d'ailleurs il s'en est long cours ça
sera aussi peut-être l'autre match à
cocher dans les prochaines rencontres
oui ben façon là
qui vous tiendra puisque je crois que
vous et salomé vous êtes un peu
originaire de le céder dès lors aussi on
a 80 m de l'équipe qui a été on a joué
là bas on été formé là bas donc il
faudra aller c'est même une chance elle
encourt aussi je vous semblent
incertaines même pas de pitié le message
est clair on recevra prochainement le
club d'elancourt n'hésitera pas alors là
c'est le droit de résistance donc proche
prochain rendez vous donc à nîmes le 2
mars et le 3 mars on verra si le
maintien est assuré
pas de soucis vous tient au courant
merci beaucoup geoffrey d'être le menu
et puis nous bonne bonne fin de saison
et on croise les doigts pour cette
peut-être remonter en nationale une
il n'y est pas encore mais merci merci
beaucoup d'être venu social côté des
filles on change la discipline à présent
oui vous je vous propose de partir à
l'encan est la rencontre de perrine
sanchez kinésithérapeute au sol dans les
airs cette imminente n est devenu cet
hiver championne du monde de vol relatif
à 4
autrement dit chute libre la discipline
des rois du ciel donc
accrochez vous à ces images d'elodie
moines j'ai fait mon premier saut
j'étais
ultra concentré en fait quand je me suis
posé pas si ça m'a pris depuis sept ans
perrine sanchez passe son temps à
regarder le monde d'en haut
pourtant au départ rien ne prédisposait
alors la jeune volleyeuse à la chute
libre
c'est en regardant les performances de
sa soeur que l'élu nantais n'a voulu
vivre ses sensations uniques
le fait de pouvoir se déplacer dans le
ciel volet de pouvoir aller un endroit à
un autre de telle façon comme je vais
décider
7 cette possibilité-là de voler
perrine a connu une ascension fulgurante
championne du monde de vol relatif à 4
devant les américaines en décembre
dernier à 28 ans l'a surnommé pépettes
déploie ses ailes dans le ciel avec une
toute autre ampleur
maintenant dans quatre étudiants
d'anciennes en ce 10 mai alors qu'elle a
passé le cap
nouvel arrivé qu'après sa place là
maintenant donc y avoir un rôle aussi un
petit peu de leadership avec laurence
pour accueillir les
nouvelle dans ces grandes compétitions
se jugeant sur dimanche cet inédit
thérapeute se jette dans le vide
uniquement par amour de la discipline
la fédération internationale refusant
d'attribuer de l'argent aux vainqueurs
et aux médaillés et à l'air libre
cela donne ça attention à l'indigestion
de tour à 360 degrés
perrine et les membres de l'équipe de
france s'envole désormais vers les
championnats d'europe en bosnie en août
prochain
il retourne sur terre on fait vite que
la chute vous me disiez cent cinquante
150 km dans la chute la vitesse ça va
assez vite
effectivement faire attention pas partir
en vrille exactement on va on va passer
sur la saison 2013 de la base de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines avec
vincent couteau vous êtes chargé de
mission animation du territoire
bonsoir à vous et vous êtes accompagné
de guillaume durand le responsable est
devenu événementiel est le nouveau
responsable de la piscine avec bonsoir à
vous alors sur sur cette saison 2013 il
y a beaucoup beaucoup d'événements
évidemment dans la chute les dentitions
à douar accord là dessus dans la chute
libre
on espère bientôt medef mais on va
évidemment parler de cette saison en
long en large et en travers mais il ya
une activité que vous recevez que vous
accueillez sellers ball un sport qui est
plutôt méconnu et ce week-end il y avait
une rencontre de championnat régional au
halal à base de loisirs entre chambly et
le match
récit de ce match le horse ball est une
sorte de basket rugby à cheval deux
équipes de six joueurs s'affrontent sur
deux périodes de dix minutes pour
marquer un but dans un panier située à
trois mètres cinquante de hauteur
l'équipe en possession du ballon doit
faire trois passes minimum
le horse ball est donc un sport
spectaculaire où parfois les contacts
sont pour le moins rugueux et pas
seulement entre chevaux à partir du
moment où on se bat on s'engage pour le
ballon effectivement il peut y avoir des
des des contacts assez virulent mais il
faut savoir que le règlement est fait
pour protéger le cheval et le cavalier
donc même quand on se penche pour un
massage donc pour ramasser les ballons
de foot les parterres normalement on est
obligé si on ramasse pas le ballon de
laisser le ramasseur tranquille pour
qu'ils puissent ramasser ballon parce
que là on est exposé au danger
effectivement avant de jouer horse ball
il faut d'abord être cavaliers et
maîtriser son cheval aux trois allures
pas trot et galop
mais ce sport est aussi exigeant pour
les chevaux ils doivent être dressés
pour ne pas avoir peur du ballon
apprendre à effectuer des courses très
rapide et s'arrêter au civil des
attitudes nécessaires pour que le couple
soit performant la complicité entre le
cheval et le cavalier je veux dire si le
cheval et le cavalier ne s'entendent pas
on a un couple qui fonctionne pas et
donc c'est difficile après
un couple qui ne fonctionne pas c'est
difficile de s'intégrer dans une équipe
aussi où tout le monde va se retrouver
pour que le collectif fonctionne
correctement
dans ce derby matches s'impose face à
chambly 9 buts à 5 et assure sa montée
en championnat de france
alors évidemment à côté des compétitions
comme le rose bowl vous comptez
accueillir en 2013 notamment du tourisme
équestre c'est ça on est tout à fait on
donne vraiment un nouvel élan au centre
équestre dès cette année en développant
tout l'aspect tourisme équestre donc
voilà vous pouvez venir le samedi le
dimanche vous soyez débutants ou déjà
confirmés et puis faire une balade dans
la base de loisir profiter des 600
hectares de pleine nature et de verdure
il ya aussi beaucoup de plans d'eau
notamment la base de loisirs et je crois
que vous allez aussi mettre l'accent sur
sur le centre de voile
voilà exactement donc cette année en des
maîtresses on ouvre le nouveau tout
nouveau centre de vol donc tout neuf
donc c'est un beau cadeau
financé par la région ile de france et
donc on va avoir des nouvelles salles
tout tout neuf où on a
tout tout un nouveau centre de vrai que
nous permettre d'acquérir planche à
voile canoë kayak en location en cours
en stage et c'est donc à le découvrir
surtout que pendant la saison il ya
beaucoup de compétition que vous
accueillez dans différentes catégories
en voile que ce soit des lasers des
optimistes et c est alors il ya aussi
évidemment eu l'attribution il ya
quelques quelques temps de la ryder cup
2018 qui sera à saint quentin en
yvelines sur sur le golf national
mais il ya un golf aussi à la base de
loisirs est ce que vous allez mettre
aussi l'accent pour inciter les gens à
découvrir cette discipline qui pas
encore totalement connues du grand
public
alors oui on a la chance d'avoir deux
golfs est finalement sur le territoire
saint quentinois doit sacrément bonne
grosse dynamique knoxy ici c'est un 45
trous avec un grand grand espace de
practice et donc voilà on a pour mission
de développer le golf auprès des
scolaires donc auprès des plus petits
qui en six ans déjà sur un peu plus
grand est
et puis dans clem 2018 effectivement ça
laisse le temps de préparer et puis il
ya beaucoup de journées portes ouvertes
en fait qui permet de découvrir
l'activité
encadré par un professionnel sur du
practice faire quelques trouées quelques
approches setareh pu découvrir que ce
sport n'est n'est pas seulement réservé
aux élites mais mais pour tous
il ya eu un effet ryder cup déjà depuis
l'attribution c'était il ya deux ans et
deux ans et demi maintenant presque
trois ans il ya eu un petit effet déjà
des gens curieux qui viennent voir
comment on pourrait découvrir le golf
alors oui et le golf du coup participe
désormais de plus en plus à nos actions
aussi événementiel et de d'activités
pour tous donc dans par tout le village
la sentez vous sport qui ont organisé en
septembre il était présent avec elle
toute une structure gonflable
ils sont présents avec nous sur les
salons aussi à porte de versailles quand
on déplace un peu la base de loisirs
voilà ils sont avec nous donc du coût
est de plus en plus de monde qui a
priori ne serait pas aller au golf et
qui du coup par cette pratique va
découvrir un sport vraiment complet est
sympa
alors aujourd'hui même depuis hier il
neige beaucoup mais il faut prévoir cet
été et cet été vous vous mettez en place
en place par dont le village sportif
c'est ça oui exactement donc cet été en
fait au niveau de la piscine à vagues
nous organisons le village à d'été
sportif financée par le conseil régional
c'est de ce sont aux activités
totalement gratuite d'accès aux centres
de loisirs notamment pour les jeunes qui
n'ont pas forcément la possibilité de
partir en vacances notamment la zumba
tir à l'arc sandball beach volley pas
mal d'activités plutôt original et qu'on
n'a pas forcément l'habitude de
pratiquer ça permet de les faire
découvrir entre guillemets c'est ça
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment de
l'initiation de la découverte et à
travers de ce village on va également
mettre en place un défi un challenge
sportif intéressant de loisirs pour
dynamiser ce projet tout au long de
l'été ça me le 25 février à 18h45 si
vous me suivez en direct
il neige nous sommes pourtant en direct
et on parle natation piscine à vagues
épices volet c'est tout à fait de saison
automne hiver est passé pour se
réchauffer un petit peu pas dire voilà
exactement et alors il ya aussi des
incontournables à la base de loisirs
comme la piscine à vagues notamment
gilles la piscine à vagues qui ouvrira
cette année le 6 juillet jusqu'au 1er
septembre ou également des activités de
beach volley sandball et flag rugby vont
être mis en place d'accès gratuite pour
tous les participants
tous les clients qui vont être entré
dans l'enceinte de la piscine à vagues
manière gratuite
le sens de bol ça m'interroge c'est un
nom qui m'est inconnu
à quoi ça consiste un petit peu le
symbole et l'activité du hand mais sur
sable d'accord une activité à découvrir
vous pourrez aller tester à paradis
fiscaux aller faire la base des listes
est pour vous pour le pour le village
sportif c'est du 29 juillet au 30 août
c'est ça c'est ça exactement est alors
lié aussi à côté des découverts des
initiations il ya des compétitions un
peu incontournables comme la célèbre
ronde des butineuses au mois d'avril
c'est une course nature donc avec
plusieurs distances 9 km ou 18 km qu'on
peut faire en solo ou en duo accroché
par un filin donc on peut même pas
s'échapper sans l'autre est ce qu'on a
voulu mettre en place avec cette course
nature dont c'est la troisième édition
maintenant c'est vraiment tout un
village
tout un village nature serre que faire
comprendre aux coureurs dans quel espace
y vit donc on déplace la ferme
pédagogique sur ce village là on y met
les ruches ont fait goûter du miel qu'on
produit nous mêmes d'abord sur la base
de loisirs donc c'est vraiment un
instant sympa donc concours ou pas on
peut venir participer à cet événement et
venir découvrir ce village très bien
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
d'esprit venue ce soir sur scène où tu
avais fini puis on suivra donc tous et
tous ces événements et puis on essaiera
de découvrir ces nouveaux sports merci
beaucoup de visiteurs vous accueillez
sur la base de loisirs alors sur une
année de beausoleil on accueille à peu
près un million de visiteurs entre des
visiteurs nos activités et d'autres qui
viennent juste pour faire des pique
nique barbecue etc
merci à tous les deux merci à tous les
trois puisque vous étiez resté avec nous
prendre quelques notes avant le prochain
match pour préparer éventuellement des
activités pour cet été pour vos joueuses
merci donc à tous les trois on passe au
résultat l'essentiel du week-end
la neige la neige a de nouveau fait son
apparition ce week-end sur les terrains
de football yvelinois quelques
rencontres ont dû être reportés
notamment le match de division d'honneur
les lilas versailles en promotion
d'honneur cela a joué mais le bilan est
assez pauvre trappe concède le match nul
sur sa pelouse face à epinay 2 buts
partout et de son côté guyancourt se
déplacer à evry mais les joueurs
détiennent rennais se sont inclinés 3
buts 1 et n'ont toujours pas gagné en
2013 alors là on voit le classement au
classement justement guyancourt dans
cette poule c de promotion d'honneur et
à 35 points reste leader malgré cette
défaite mais cela revient très fort
derrière sa mort et est à égalité de
points oubliant cours n'est plus que
leader grâce à la différence de buts
en football féminin côté résultats
toujours en division de montigny a été
aussi victime des flocons le match face
à rouen n'a pu se jouer et à saint
quentin en yvelines il ya une équipe
aussi qui cartonne en ce moment ce sont
les féminines d'elancourt elles se sont
imposés très tranquillement chez vous
oui oui vous lisez bien le fruit de 8,0
à rueil malmaison un score fleuve
elle domine de la tête et des épaules
leur championnat de promotion ligue
d'ailleurs vous découvrirez cette équipe
de toujours invaincu cette saison
prochainement dans le 7-8 sport on passe
à présent basket alors oui parce qu'elle
lui autres disciplines autres résultats
voyez un événement ce week-end un petit
peu wilfried lors de cette 20e journée
de national 2 e homme trap a retrouvé le
goût de la victoire sur son parquet face
à lorient les joueurs trapy se sont
imposés 88 à 83 chez les femmes
l'entente le chesnay versailles a encore
perdu ils font elles font tout
simplement du surplace les joueuses de
vinko berdych se sont inclinés face à
leurs dauphines l'aggravant shon 83 à 65
quatrième défaite consécutive pour les
yvelinoises au classement trappe restent
avant-derniers de nationale 2 avec 26
points car dans le même temps
effectivement le douzième le mans s'est
aussi imposé face à juvisy la lutte pour
le maintien se précise entre trappe
le mans est énorme chez les filles
l'entente le chesnay versailles reste
leader de sa poule 1 de nationale 2 mais
à égalité de points avec gravenchon et
bourges
les coéquipières de virginie aurensan
donc plus du tout de joker et vont
devoir vite réagir sous peine de devoir
échapper tout simplement les playoffs
c'est une vraie contre performance amis
étaient venus sur ce plateau tout se
passait très bien pour eux quasiment un
sans faute en début de saison est plus
là depuis la reprise ça devient très
très compliqué on passe au hand
oui 16e journée de nationale 2 les
féminines de montigny chez le 9e
plouvorn bas se sont imposés 28 à 26
avec cette neuvième victoire de la
saison les joueuses de stéphane paysans
confortent leur cinquième classe 5e
place au classement avec 44 points à 10
points du leader rennais il y avait du
roller hockey aussi l encours oui
nationale 3 les chocs d'elancourt à la
traditionnelle équipe de roller hockey
ibai se sont imposés 5 buts à 3 face à
pont de metz
ils confortent ainsi leur troisième
place au classement ils sont toujours
meilleures défenses de nationale 3 sport
américain tojo après le roller hockey et
le football américain
oui toujours un sport sport américain
premier match à domicile dans l'élite
pour pour les templiers d'elancourt et
gros carton d'ailleurs ils ont atomisé
les centaures de grenoble malgré un
début de match compliqué des décisions
arbitrales discutables
ils ont amené d'ailleurs qui ont amené
le touch donne des centaures les
templiers se sont tout de suite repris
grâce à notamment un excellent match du
quarterback américain vini roth la
nouvelle star du club
score final 34 à 7 après deux journées
et l'encours est en tête du championnat
d'élite
voilà pour ces images du match et ils
ont été substitués aussi supporter oui
je penserai à saisir et à faire la
différence exactement cette saison les
temples y ont reçu un renfort de choix
armé de pompons au bord du terrain les
cheerleaders que nous avions reçu sur le
plateau il ya quelques mois vous vous en
souvenez wilfried on était bien entouré
elles sont une dizaine à chanter à
danser à la gloire des templiers lors
des matches à domicile
nous avons suivi leurs performances ce
week-end à quelques minutes de leur
première apparition aux côtés des
templiers de cheerleaders peaufinent
leurs chorégraphies
au menu pyramides humaines s'opére yeux
et figure en tout genre autant dire que
l'on ne s'improvise pas tirs
il faut être motivé dans ce gymnaste
enfin prête à avoir des sensations âgés
de 16 à 25 ans alison cindy laurie les
six autres cheers ont presque tout un
passé de danseuse ou de gymnastes des
passions communes qui ont renforcé la
cohésion de l'équipe
créé en septembre dernier et dévoué aux
templiers
il faut en fait encouragé les joueurs
sans les gêner le public penser au
public
faire faire des tas de choses pour que
pour que tout se passe bien pour que le
match soit un petit peu comme en
amérique on est un peu comme une petite
une petite famille déjà bas l'ambiance
des templiers nous aident à rentrer dans
ce dans cette ambiance là lors de cette
rencontre entre les templiers et les
centaures le thermomètre affiche des
températures sous les zéro degré pas de
quoi décourager les cheer ce qui assure
quand même le spectacle au bord du
terrain
elles auront le droit elle aussi à leur
compétition puisqu'elle vont participer
cette saison au challenge régional de
cheers
quelle jolie figure vous étiez avec les
shaders
non j'ai pas bougé aperçu à la fin c'est
alors vous n'aviez pas les pompes et pas
moi c'était julie rocha soir est non
c'est facile merci anthony qu'on trouve
lundi prochain pour le 7-8 sport dès 18h
30 ans directeur replay à suivre sur
notre site internet
oui n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à le
commenter ce 7,8 sport sur twitter et
nous donner tous les résultats de vos
clubs à lundi prochain bonne soirée